hello what's up folks happy Monday I'm
Eric that's Nick hey what's up uh not
much
Nick I guess apparently I think today
there was an update for pub G on Xbox
one I will give you guys kind of a
breakdown or rundown of those changes as
we hop into the game one of them is as
you can see you can you can do
first-person I think right yeah that's a
change yeah that's one of the changes
let me kind of give you guys it's it's
mainly quality of life desert map is
still not in I know it's still not in on
the Xbox version we are playing on a 1x
so I think most of Nick and i's kind of
experience so far with at least on
console pub G is that we've paid mostly
on a normal Xbox one yeah which is kind
of it was kind of suspect um a fair
amount of crashes yeah it's generally
janky I mean look at it right now it
already looks janky but it's better
though so part of the update was to fix
some of those crashes so there should be
addressed they addressed a number of
known crashes I'm gonna kind of run
through the gamut here of updates so as
of today gameplay why is there a mcc's l
eration I think you can show that off
right can now be adjusted by players via
the in-game option so in the settings
there's a thing called game acceleration
at the very bottoms at the bottom that
wasn't there before so you can kind of
tweak that I know that was the thing
that was bothering people player weapon
damage has been increased against
vehicles thank God because that has been
a problem plaguing the Xbox version okay
because at the end in the final round I
mean I won't lie I do it all the time
because on PC this would never work yeah
getting a vehicle and you can just drive
around in circles in the finals in like
the final area yeah and like you
survived and you run people over and
it's kind of like a cheap way versus on
PC you can easily shoot down a car
explode it like shooting out of the car
so I think that they increasing the
damage on the car it's gonna prevent
people from being able to do that and
from their notes it also says they will
continue to monitor player feedback and
telemetry and make further balancing
adjustments as needed in future updates
in regards to damage against vehicles
yeah another one is having the
fpp first person solo matchmaking queue
will now be available for na EU and
oceanic servers as you would saw we will
open other modes within those regions as
concurrency allows the other the next
fix is fix an issue that caused indoor
lighting and shadows to appear too dark
and bluish analog stick acceleration
added while exiting the plane and while
parachuting in terms of optimization
PhysX performance enhancements a server
FPS slightly increased as well as client
FPS slightly increased hard for me to
tell the difference since this is a the
one X is a little bit sharper than the
normal Xbox one yeah so but from the you
know five to ten minutes that you were
in playing just now I don't know if it
was just the one X or also the update
but I noticed some of the frame stuff
was better or slightly just the yeah wow
this up no there's gotta be some good IV
something Nick and some VFX received
slight optimisation you also have now
the option for music on and off fix the
UI issue that occurred when multiple
players attempted to loot from the same
source and also the bug fixes so we will
be checking this out we'll see how Nick
does we'll see if he gets any chicky
dinners again
of course we're on console so no desert
map but yeah Rock yep yeah I kind of
went off the path so I think it's just
gonna be him and if you guys didn't know
we stream every day at 11 a.m.
normally Wednesday is our lobby day the
lobby will probably be at least on
hiatus for one maybe two more weeks as
we kind of fine-tune the studio a little
bit and some people are also out this
week so just giving you guys a heads up
on that I'll be in the YouTube chat and
twitch chat in case watch hat if you
guys have any questions comments send
them our way
and we'll try to answer them and/or have
a fun little chat with you guys make
sure you guys if you guys haven't
already if you want to view more lash
games and things like I saw that little
pop in see clippin make sure you hit sub
or like on Twitch so you guys are
notified as to when we go live no boy
you know there were no weapon fire no
shoes WTF so no shoes well part of that
is to kind of make it so you're a little
bit more quiet right so people can't
hear you yeah it's a I think it's an
urban myth yeah that's fine he likes to
go uh die-hard style John McClane we
don't need no shoes here if you guys
don't know what no I don't want to die
hard is or who John McClane is I implore
you to watch that movie
die hard very good movie did you need a
vest wasn't that vest was it I thought
it was the best where I was a backpack
my bad my B here's the worst thing is
the navigate navigating the menus okay
well the inventory stuff is cool but I
mean so let me just kind of cut off cut
it off before before it goes to pass
here that
why are you playing on console one is to
check out the update and - oh hey a lot
of people are gonna be like hey PC
better yes we normally play on PC
I think it's plays better on the PC but
it's nice that there's a platform for
people that don't own a PC yes I'll say
this game is so much better on PC it is
it's night and day
the difference between this game on xbox
in this game on PC is night and day yeah
I would play this game on PC a thousand
times before I would play on xbox but
with that being said not all my friends
have Xbox is right yeah so what I
usually do is play or no they all they
all have Xbox they don't have PC yeah
yeah that's what I was like are you sure
yes another way right so most my friends
back home obviously not have pcs so what
what we like to do on the weekends is
like to play together and the only way
to do that is to play on xbox and so
that gives it like more different user
base right different user base obviously
I think I got a question on what mics
are we using we are using electro-voice
re 20s rode mics there are eau de good
podcast mics they're kind of expensive
though so if you're thinking about
buying a mic Sadow's you might not want
to start with this one
there's a couple good USB options if
you're looking at that or if you want to
do the XLR options this mics pretty good
but a little pricey it's like $450 mic
whereas you could get like a like a Yeti
or something like that for like less
than ninety you want to say which is
also a solid white but yeah okay feeling
good right now
what kind of FPS are you getting on the
Xbox X oh you got some pay killers got
some isn't it didn't they say like it's
like locked at 30 and then probably like
fluctuates yeah I believe so so or wait
is that yeah yeah yeah I think even on
the exits locked at 30 yeah it's um it
is funny when you look at this game
compared to some other games it's funny
kind of looking when you look at the
stats between them but you know I think
they're they're working hard to get it
where they want it to be and it'll be
there eventually but it's gonna take a
little while it's definitely not 60 as
Geist
shock has mentioned but yes pub G on
Xbox one X and the Xbox one are locked
at 30 so push I go you think I should
try to go to the city I told you I watch
more pop G than I play so I can't really
help you out other than like making sure
you boost and stuff these homeboy oh
yeah a couple guys landed down here well
pennington probably not opening up
playing today with us but if we start
doing pub G stuff more often maybe but
it's a possibility first time watching
you all are awesome thank yous is on my
dizzle thanks also man I just miss it
gilligan McCleary rode mics are the best
yeah we're enjoying these for our
podcast stuff and also for in here in
the stream I think some other streamers
also have this mic but again it's a
little bit of a heavier investment so if
you're just starting to stream might not
be the best option to start with but
still if you can afford it sure very
good solid mic it's this better than
fortnight I think it's different still
and I think there's always gonna be the
debate back and forth he's been a lot of
players in terms of like which game they
like more I think it's it's good that
there's both and that you can play
either either one and which one you
prefer
also I think that sometimes like players
tend to gravitate to
where their friends are playing so you
know obviously if there's more like
these games especially their good solo
but definitely as you had mentioned yeah
and the weekend you're playing with it
but it's way more if this game is
infinitely more fun and I'm sure if
fortnight's the same way I just haven't
had a lot of experience with it
these games are infinitely more fun when
you're playing with other people and
like you're like hanging out and not
only that like with these kind of games
you could spend and I mean it's
definitely gonna happen on this stream -
especially with Xbox yeah we'll probably
and look around for like an hour and
then we won't notice someone and they'll
just block ya behind it and it's all
over it happened with me and Sam on
Friday we're playing on a PC and you
know like we probably spent like a good
you know 10-15 minutes per game just
kind of like looting up and getting set
and then like some you just kind of get
in the Harry situation and you just kind
of get murked but yeah I mean like I
think anyone that's watching that
understands Poggi you battle royale
stuff he's like should know that that's
probably gonna happen I mean we could
potentially next game I could just tell
me Nick go to the school and we can get
instant action I'd probably die but
maybe get some kills yeah will do so
this this one I'm gonna try to play a
little conservatively because I find if
you do play conservatively on Xbox
you can usually last until the top 5
it's pretty easy ok you might not you're
setting yourself up for potential
failure but that's alright I fit with
the promises that people will be like oh
we didn't you didn't kill anyone you got
the top 5 that's like they give and take
if you want action you're probably not
gonna make it into the top 10 hey
there's that boat coming at you - yeah
yeah Austin Jackson I don't I don't
think you're totally right there he's
basically saying he still thinks the
Xbox one next to him doesn't look that
great compared to a PC you can build for
half the price I don't know if he could
build a computer for $250 and have it
look like exponentially better than this
unless somebody can improve me wrong 250
is not very much to spend unless for
some reason like you're saying for like
a PC yeah because he's saying for half
the price of an Xbox one X which is an
Xbox one extra should be five hundred
five correct and half the price of that
would be a $250 PC so I don't know again
this is for a different demographic I
think that most players that play PC
games will probably play pubs UMPC this
is for all the folks that don't have a
PC haven't built one or maybe don't have
one that's good enough to run pub G
there's a lot of people that probably
just own an Xbox one or a One X that
want to enjoy this game too so we're
gonna get some action here cuz this is
right on the flight path they're
definitely not better the graphics are
not better than PC there's no way no way
no way
so for I'm Cara LaMotte I think it's a
very serviceable for for being on the
console for a puppy yeah I think that
the update has helped a little bit but
again my my experience is more with I
think pre-release right like they listed
on Xbox as like pre-release ok so we'll
see if there's gonna further optimize
we'll see how it goes and how it
continues but yeah like I think I think
I notice a little bit of the changes
that they put in and that's just one
patch and it's only been a month so if
they continue to optimize yeah we're
gonna be good should have played fpp I
mean we can yeah we did appealing DX
Master six one yeah I
I've never played fpp on Xbox so that
should be pretty interesting
twin coconuts asking is Hornets
something that console guys should stick
to singing as pop G is poorly optimized
for console if you're already playing
fortnight sure you could probably stick
to it I think puppy's gonna slowly but
surely get optimized into a better place
but if you're enjoying fortnight already
and you're not feeling pub G yet stick
to port and I kind of just keep kind of
continue to monitor the updates it until
it gets to a place that you want to play
pub G yeah yeah and kind of a thing
between we get a lot of the talk with
you know whether it's a fortnight and
pop G the thing that I really like about
pub G's the realistic ness in the sense
that you know like they're later
different types of games like overwatch
has very like cartoony based care or
taro baby's not here we have one that's
comparing them as games art styles okay
so you have to get very like oh [ __ ]
there's guy he doesn't know where I am
you better make it happen let's use this
can he not hear your footsteps cuz I can
hear your footsteps you can and they
turn off your audio for you
[Music]
now a toll easy to glue your element of
surprise he had no idea you probably
could have just kept sneaking on his ass
okay he walked outside on you we do that
you yes Oh
is this funny how how quickly the
advantage where the hell did he go he
went outside I don't know where he is
outside though
well like he definitely was outside he's
on the right really run away
I would why where he's waiting for you
to show up while he's posted up behind
something so he can Merc you know he had
all the advantage in the world oh my god
yours you are so risky cuz this guy ran
away no I know I think he's straight up
like he was like waiting for you in a
bear spot alright where's a circle Decco
asking so does the patch make it run
better it's hard for me to say because
my experience has been on a normal Xbox
one whereas we were playing on xbox and
1x which was already slightly better
than the walk like I think I don't know
slightly better is the right term if it
it was definitely better for whatever
you want to say you just got bamboozled
says frosty flopper oh yeah I did
definitely uh really amateur mistake
yeah I should have shot I should have
got right
I thought he saw me to be honest Logan
horseman or a horseman asking if I
already have it on PC is it worth buying
on Xbox I don't think it's worth buying
on Xbox unless you have more friends
playing on xbox and on PC yeah if you
don't then I would just stick to pcs 6
PC also I prefer mouse keyboard
Amiens me too controller obviously and
it is funny because when I first started
working here I really never played like
mouse keyboard shooters and then and
then I like quickly picked up this I
think this game was really the one that
was like oh I like this
Donnie cash says what is the update
because I've just played a couple hours
and ain't [ __ ] changed Donnie
make sure you have the right update I've
also posted it in the YouTube chat for
those asking what's different that
article will tell you everything that's
different
posted by our Oscar days and
the UK thanks so check out the full
points there make sure on that you
update that new update I think or is it
like I forgot the number so just make
sure if you weren't already in pop G
already like maybe you need a back out
to update it I'm not sure we we made
sure beforehand that we have the update
it did it auto it did it auto for us
overnight so if you guys have Nathan
partner wants us to check in the next
game if they fix the glitch where you
get stuck in a roof wall when
parachuting in oh yeah I can try but
also even before that like if I ever
wish I'd go I want to go to the shore if
I ever got stuck in the roof it would
like it would glitch out a little bit
but I would still kind of like fall
through to the inside now I would be
okay yeah I haven't seen that like
personally okay Altair Darius in game
saw chat asking is it easier aiming
shooting than a PC no way no way no way
oh god save it
nailed it stuck the landing that was
close
I would definitely stick to PC if you
can altair darius but he says he's
looking forward to buying it on ps4
whenever that comes out yeah they said
that they had mentioned that they wanted
to do that
there was no ETA on a win so who knows
are we currently in the basement at our
mom's house no we're in the sub yes
interactive building in terms I'm pretty
sure I read that question or a question
correct from life games and YouTube
might be my favorite comment that's ever
been right
all right I want to go to the show all
right my twin
sure you told me 45 alive we haven't
killed anyone we saw one person we blew
it yeah but we didn't die either so I
guess that's okay I'll let him know
where we were home still I died this
weekend in the dumbest way ever okay to
ride a motorcycle and there was a there
was a like a you know an orange like
cone and I bumped into the cone and I
died did you have like low hell no I had
full health how do you die from that
from a cone I know I was very upset
draping Gertler in you to Chad says I
have an ex and I have never had a
problem with crashing and falling
through roofs or stairs any load
smoothly but yeah yeah me so the
thinking is Draven it's like I said it
is at least incrementally better if not
whatever term you want to use on an X
compared to an Xbox one if you played
the two you would notice kind of how
different that is so they could have
been more problem on it problematic
excuse me on an xbox one versus an X but
they they have a blanket general
statement saying they fix a lot of
crashes and issues so hopefully that's
one of them but we can try it next game
after this shit's very um Nick gets to a
top five which apparently is very easy
on the I think so Walker asking is it
running better than before the patch
from what I can tell I want to say yes
but I don't know if that's placebo
effects but yeah but again our
experience is we played a lot of Xbox or
we played it on Xbox and not so much on
the X so it's probably harder for us why
would you drop that I made a mistake I
wanted to use one the desert map is not
on Xbox it's unfortunately so sad we
will be updating you on case Botcon when
that happens so stay tuned all right can
you give a rating for this game as ubi
kayu
Oh in fact GameSpot reviews games and
are Michael higham I don't know if he
didn't review ok so they reviewed the PC
version
we haven't get an official number for
the Xbox version but I would assume it
would be gotta be at least one lower
right a quite lower than uh would you
say quite lower yeah we gave it an eight
right yeah I recall correctly so we gave
up G PC and eight if I was to rate the
one or the X the X would probably be a
seven I guess no you think lower man
good thing we don't review games
what is aim acceleration it's probably
the speed at which the crosshair moves I
would assume that's that's my guess I'm
sorry that I don't have the right yeah
sure yeah that's what your audio yeah
just so I can hear the Oh gameplay yeah
I was I turn you up you're already at
maximum so I'm not 100% sure instinct x
darkness but that's my my guess at least
did they fix the game crashing issue
watch Ryan that's what they say
they said that they have like the
blanket statement is that they've added
are they fixed a bunch of game crashes
and issues omnipotence ons exclamation
mark I subscribe thanks for subscribing
thanks you really appreciate it and I
hope you enjoy that hot GameSpot content
I need some I need some protection I
realized I still naughty vest
I haven't even found a level-one vest
it's late why are you guys not sleeping
it's because it's early for us it's
11:20 ok 3 in the u.s. here on the we
are in California very early for us
skinny ape 74 hey at a fortnight f of G
which would you prefer it's really hard
for me to answer
I haven't played enough fortnight and
I've to be honest barely played that
much pub G I I tend to enjoy watching it
more than playing it what have you
played for tonight the battle relvar
okay so we can't speak to that but I
want to say our Michael hi remember near
the water I want to say our Michael hi
um is gonna do kind of like a comparison
at some point I don't know when that's
gonna be because he's currently at CES
but I'm sure if you want to find out
about that
[Music]
that'll be relatively hopefully soon in
the coming weeks the two games
aesthetically look very different once
kind of more cartoony and ones more
realistic I have heard in terms of like
just fidel like game fidelity like the
way things run and crashes and like FPS
and everything I've heard that fortnight
is better okay well for tonight it's
also different in the sense that
gameplay mechanic wise because there's
building and english traps too so I see
it's kind of crazy actually watching
fortnight knowing that's a Battle Royale
style just watching people just like
build up words and like across the land
also I think like while you're farming
in fortnight you kind of use a hammer
pick to break down walls and things like
that to get treasure oh there's no time
to be wiping your face or motorcycle or
scratch my nose so it's gonna be just
which game do you prefer Oh which
gameplay mechanics do you prefer good
job there buddy
again so yeah I would say how dare you
call fortnight cartooning what Oh am I
supposed oh yeah how would how would you
guys describe this guy if it's alright
you know what you're right it's not
cartoony it's I mean I would almost say
that like overwatch is like cartooning
in an anime way and yeah like maybe
that's too general of a statement but I
guess I don't know weird my boy class so
yeah I think that it's it's more of like
which style of game do you like also
like I said these games are for me if I
was playing heavily motivated by who I
know that are also playing the games and
if they're playing one versus the other
I'll probably have more of a fun time
playing one versus the other but that's
not to say that playing solo isn't fun
still in either one
that's just how I personally game yeah I
prefer to be other people I think you
can play both there's a lot of I mean
like granted their streamers and they're
probably just trying to mix it up but a
lot of those the pubsey streamers also
Jeff stream fortnight and I think they
enjoy it so alright so what is the final
circle look like well no not the final
circle you call it vivid not cartoony as
as isolated okay
all right someone else like there's
other people there saying like it's
pretty cartooning I just like the
realistic nosov like pub G where it
feels like real like Hunger Games where
it's like real kinds of weapons that
like we know it really exists
it's like your character looks like a
real human mm-hmm I like that I like the
human side of things how's the FPS a
khylin at seven one nine it's definitely
better on an X and I want to say I don't
know if it's placebo effect or not but
with the patch there's a server and
client FPS upgrades like minor I believe
is slightly increased so server fps and
client FPS slightly increased so I don't
know if it's just a 1x or not but it
definitely at least our first glance
looks better than what I recall from
watching Jake and Nick play when they
were playing on the console previously
Boman spark saying it seems too laggy
it's giving me a headache is it the
stream or the game I don't know
hopefully it's not the stream I'll let
the rest of chat tell me if it's laggy
but I think you're the first person
that's told me but the stream main I
feel like it could just be the game I
feel pretty confident it's again okay
okay that's fair woods Hyperion 72 I
would say that fortnight is more
animated that's fair
can't dispute that stream looks fine
says coop thank you how do you free look
on X bone you're gonna hold down what is
it RB right bumper right bumper oh you
see these homies up here yeah that's
probably just one person right you're
not playing squads yeah I like your
strategy here just kind of staying on
the outskirts of the circle up top where
you can see everything sees guy sees guy
thank you thank God Nick we finally got
one in the back we got one in the back
boys yeah I'm feeling pretty good
actually
you should probably definitely homies
here I boost up though when you can
definitely homies here energy drink yeah
yeah maybe some painkillers yeah but
you're gonna have to move soon right cuz
the circles coming in no you're not in
the circle circle closing I should have
really looted him before but not too
late let's see I think you're pretty
good though you got three painkillers
three first-aid kit wet doors just
closed two seconds ago okay so I can
focus just focus I can sneak up on
people a lot easier on painkillers in
there
you don't need new kills I am turning
off the gameplay audio for Nick's sake I
will lower it later
[Music]
that's a very precise they're bargain
1414 twenty seven point six seven second
stream delay what is this cable TV
surprise you could get it down to that
you didn't want the bike on okay that's
fine
does it run better with the update
asking King lows I want to say yes don't
know if it's just placebo effects should
you hear that people are still doing the
vehicle thing be sure they didn't just
take the bike yeah you're driving around
oh there's a there's a little bat we're
alright I don't know oh god I don't know
which way it's coming from but I I'm
trying to not get hit by this car loot
getting hit by car is the worst thing
because there's the car okay
seeing that next we'll get to your
question in terms of the inventory in a
sec okay we got two cars up there as hot
right one building I hear a car behind
me
that's to my right now like a lawnmower
at your house they're like four cars
there so I'm in the circle I kind of
like this spot because I got the tree
here this circle will be right on my
back and I got these two rocks paying
forever we can play first person next
game yeah yeah we'll do it
that's I hate sniping on Xbox is creepin
it's just like doing laps Texan
Wolverine actually cars are gonna in
this patch apparently cars will blow ups
faster now that yeah higher weapon
damage so we'll see that into effect
potentially all right we need to shoot a
car so I just heard a little sniper oh I
see somebody I think Keith Richards
liver 420 yeah do you guys think aiming
is worse compared to other console games
yeah possibly only because there's a is
there do you know if there's a chat do
you know if there's a missed in this
game cuz most console games oh there's a
car areas those console games have a
missus it's a problem plaguing Xbox
bizzy's gonna see you right yeah but he
so the thing is he won't get out of the
car to shoot
he'll just continue to join he doesn't
know about that update bro
it's so boring I hate that alright so
you don't know about that hot update or
do you say update it's 46 seconds it's
up the hill there's definitely somebody
in that house I'm stunned
nobody's fired up Chris McCallum if you
haven't shared your dislikes for the
Xbox version of please some more I feel
like we have it's mainly FPS how how it
runs how I would say keyboard mouse is
better precise aiming but outside it
some of that stuff like I still play
this game like all weekend on Xbox like
I use I don't have a PC at home I play
all weekend slanted NIC palms are sweaty
yet mom um forget
it's a frame rate better now according
to asking Ricky Velasquez according to
the update sure it should be slightly
better uh client-side and server-side
that's why I said slightly increased
okay there's a car there there's a
dossier yeah there's a box to your right
let's probably out looted oh god you're
out in the open I gotta get in the heart
that Jeep is coming for you oh oh god
damn we're win the crown he's literally
laying on the ground
alright tough town top five oh you're
setting yourself up man
top ten I just want to call you out on
it that's all uh you can you can shoot
people who are inside cars but since the
aiming is not as precise on console it's
like alright f at first Percy alright
next next match I don't want a sign Nick
you have to you said you would and the
stream wants it just do it first person
and go to the school okay how could how
could the inventory be better it's hard
to say because inventory management on
consoles so tough compared to like how
fast you can drag stuff with the
keyboard okay I don't know I think
someone else had mentioned like having
the cursor like in Minecraft would help
potentially that yeah oh thanks for the
call uh says Christmas being sarcastic
yeah I know how'd I do how do I think
you're being a little unfair with a
preview status of the game but the game
is out right the game is out like the
full game is out granted it's still like
you mentioned it's not the full like
version I'm just telling it how it is
based off of the game right now and it's
tough because I can make the comparison
to PC now maybe that's not necessarily
fair but my um both exists and they're
both out so I'm trying to give protects
me and being like oh so it's easy to get
the top 5 yes exactly but I'm just
trying to give people that my opinion
now that's it's it's my opinion Nick's
opinion it's not it's like the all like
that at the end all be all but I'm just
trying to say from my perspective that's
the stuff I notice and see in comparison
and that's
and it's hard because not every like I
said not everyone has both platforms but
if you did have both platforms that's
the advice I would give so you know are
you guys gonna make a monster hunter
worlds win release I didn't know you can
actually make a world we'll definitely
be playing it skinny ape we're gonna
play the beta next week when it's out
the last beta before the actual release
of the game and will probably be
covering it for the weeks to come so
stay tuned for Monster Hunter world if
you if that's what you're interested in
do you think the desert map will come to
console yeah it definitely eventually
come to console Geoff Gavin eventually
yeah like absolutely it's coming but are
you gonna go to the school nice all
right in my friends are backing me up
though they didn't see the guy in the
grass either yeah I didn't see him
because well part of the problem I was
so fixated on the car that I was not
looking at the grassy Lane literally was
literally prone like like if if this is
the tree here and you were behind the
tree he was like at an angle laying down
and I think it's because he probably
heard the apartments are school school
okay
and also what I'm gonna do after this is
because you're getting crazy spam yeah
after you die I'm gonna go full camera
so you can turn off notifications yeah
we're gonna turn off notifications all
right guys let's chill actually here why
don't you do this too
can you go out hop into settings and and
in this and increase the aim
acceleration to like max I just want to
see what that does settings and then go
to the bottom and go like 210 or
whatever the max is yeah okay cool and
tell me if you feel a difference there's
gonna be great send him to the school to
get schooled as Jay Baer says alright
whoever's doing that shout out bro la P
nikkor sloppy nick or relax dawg the
Knickerbockers we're fine also I feel
like that name was like babe but anyways
I said it correctly so good try
yeah we're gonna have to fix we're gonna
have to fix that yeah Sean who knows
let's throw hands he's got a gun down
he's got a gun - you can't has no idea
that I'm here you see you bye bye bye
give the shake and bake baby cuz you
guys shake it before you bake it oh god
I don't legit Ricky Bobby oh my god that
can get that quick
alright gimme why is it not working I
don't know it's not working I don't know
just don't worry about that can't you
pick it up normally you know because
you're getting spammed by messages or
that guy go
I don't know he's price low upstairs did
you is it in the gunfire mode that you
like oh okay
I can oh my god well this person is so
annoying that's fine you were gonna get
blocked so fast my boy my boy he's not
your boy though cuz dude you are so
alright sorry sorry sorry it just makes
me nervous as a viewer just watching you
kind of like slowly grab stuff while we
know people are in the school we don't
want to get schooled like Jay Baer said
we gotta at least get a kill or two here
I can't hear anything I'll turn it up I
turned out thought it was just yolo
swaggins it baby find that action make
it happen alright we've already dead
body here well I hear somebody the above
you
in stairs this is really annoying sir
yeah whoever you are
it doesn't matter no we're just eating
it we're feeding into it I'm gonna
ignore it I'm gonna ignore it like
everyone in chat and watching the stream
should do the same
guru did he go I don't know I can hear
him all I can hear myself the hell is
you here too right yeah I heard I
definitely heard him for sure
it sounds like above you but then you
just checked above you right yeah
well the school is pretty big so they
probably just looting right now we'll be
reporting oh oh shotgun action is he out
here I think is upstairs on the roof
amazed iam there in the gymnasium there
is uh you did leave an Arg no they're
upstairs dude they're totally upstairs
all right I'm gonna just go up there and
hopefully I get killed because I need to
turn this thing off yeah that's why I
don't understand why you haven't been
trying to do that this whole time no oh
wait now that's a piece of paper
American Beauty yeah we are gonna turn
that off bed I said after this match but
it turns out we can't die fast enough or
we can just straight up exit and call it
a day I'm gonna straight up here hold on
turn the camera I'll go full camera go
ahead we're gonna turn them off how do I
turn these off you gotta go into
settings not an account oh I think I
just saw it go back down to preferences
notifications there yep alright cool
alright and now let me quickly block
this person no wait it doesn't matter
he's not gonna send you anything right
now
all right back to the game okay all
right all right here we go and we didn't
die which is good although Nick probably
wants to die cuz he doesn't wanna play
first person no boy or put the camera
over it yeah that's true
but the noise would keep happening which
is annoying logged in and reported him
on my phone I'm at work thanks JD oh yes
yeah
okay quick quickly I'll back up he's got
nowhere to hide right it shows up on the
wall
this shows how bad a meanness yeah suck
it clean full 203 194 he got headshot it
Wow Nikki margarita I'm not that bad I
mean I'm not good but I'm not that bad
you guys gotta admit that who who wins
the one B ones in cod you do by a
thousand I hate he's got a lot of stuff
this is good this is good level two best
if anyone has ever seen no you don't
need that huh oh yeah dot site little
red dot okay red dot man how did they
lose the red dot and you didn't even
have a site swap the no you're good
you're good you're good you're good
that's good all right yeah we need some
bandages or something or a health pack
oh wait first we in the circle urn I
don't know dude oh we're right on the
edge of the circle oh this is chill
right on this wall
maybe well you see if anybody runs the
past well take a painkiller or something
or do you need to right now who I need I
need Ambo mission I need em you can
reload too by the way
backseat gaming baby at its finest oh
you have a met kid that's good cause Oh
lame that's correct if I if he'd killed
me I wouldn't say damn that aim is [ __ ]
oh yeah put you at level ten how does
that feel how did the aim acceleration
feel was it the same Oh was it the same
did you not feel a different I didn't
feel a different wait you know what dude
what I didn't get apply maybe we'll
apply a next game then all right how
much you want to bet there's someone on
one of these this is the most cringe Pub
G gameplay I've ever seen hey man who
killed somebody
it could be cringy er all right dog
whatever good we could have shot that
guy and died and then you would have
definitely said it was the cringe is
there's a grip on the ground if you
needed it
take it reload your dad yeah we did
don't worry we're on it thank you though
thank you pain forever we did reload
that gun throw backpack on I don't know
I don't right I don't think so
that's why I don't like first person I
kids on what I have i dilute baby
how does no one been in here there's
maybe nobody drop down this is he's that
motorcycle helmet too this is a hot spot
to be dropping dog that's cool maybe
maybe people just don't go to the school
on a console scared that got you the
price scared did
I'm gonna rock the 8k because we have
more ammunation ha Yuda pramana how do
you guys think about the console player
use mouse and keyboard I think it's
something yeah it's yeah I think there's
a player that used to do that on destiny
I was like that's kind of unfair like
this there's only a difference in
precision I'll tell you that
there's a massive difference all right
now let me go in this room and now I'll
do what you told me but I mean
technically if it's available you can't
really alright so if we go to setting'
oh no it is say so on PC you have to hit
apply so you couldn't even tell huh
maybe it's better that you it's at a
higher maybe that's how you got it
because you're able to like so it
affects this right it does feel really
fast
we'll just work on a 1050 Ti I think so
Nick D'Souza I'm pretty sure that's that
should be totally fine
god I someone's here antenna what why in
your head now it's in my head I know
dude okay seven seven seven I just want
to say it fails to aim and kill the next
person it's because he turned down aim
acceleration let it be known chicken
dinner on you guys I hope so we got you
a wish I've actually never won a solo
chicken dinner on Xbox yet but that
means I really played that much solo I
only play like with my friends if I'm
gonna play so long I'll just play on PC
unless you're at home in which case yeah
well it's just gonna sound crazy but
sometimes when I'm at home and I'm like
it's like a weekend I'm like I really
want to play pup G I will come into the
office on like a Saturday I do it all
the time what's up Michael Nima what's
up Jake
I don't know just Jake oh shut up Jake
Forks but I don't have any I have enough
13 I just want to reiterate thank you
guys so much for tuning in today to a
pub G console updates livestream thanks
friends we're streaming every day except
this Wednesday at 11:00 a.m. so if you
haven't subscribed or hit like on a na
or follow on Twitch please do that so
you guys get notified we are talking
about aim acceleration because that is a
thing now on console from the update so
default is 5 you can go up to 10 I'm on
7
I'm Emirates can't can't I'm right -
can't you think pub G is gonna get
ported on to ps4 yeah I think so
essentially yeah it's just a matter I
think they've already said they they
didn't say window so now what about at
1050 I think it should run out of 1050 I
match are going though though I would
assume it runs fine on a 980 so what's
the frames at Eric Crawford assets
locked at 30 you know Bob we'd like
fluctuate so we're coming in hot
have you guys seen the trailers for an
open world survival prison game called
scum I am NOT DX master I'll try to take
a look and see what that sounds pretty
cool I've been seeing people starting to
play more of a scale of tarkoff
does anyone been here maybe maybe maybe
[Music]
it does feel very laggy now I wonder if
that's kind of why the desert maps not
into there's probably more stuff going
on oh yeah oh yeah and I mean they're
also like talking about their that doors
open didn't you open it nope nope you
got somebody here sign sign Nick uh if
you want a more in-depth evaluation of
aim acceleration we're gonna have to
just like hide in the corner and then
like check it out
we could try checking our next game just
to see what the difference is that like
one versus ten and then also if it's
just like a de-essing
or if it's just you know how fast you're
you know how fast is like left to right
up to down is on on the sticks so we'll
try to do that next guy just remind me I
had a long way to go infinite dev says
scum is taking forever but we'll never
be as good as Daisy I don't know enough
so yeah switch gameplay twigs twigs toe
I just discovered the chat stuff on on
like the PC version and I I like to I
like to like freak people out and be
like hey what's up guys like my name is
Mike McCarty because I like to prank
Mike I'd be like hey I got exclusive
switch codes for pub G hit me up on
Twitter and Mike is a bunch of DMS Paul
Simpson says I think game accelerations
makes the cross I would assume crosshair
move faster the longer you hold the
movement so it might be best is set to
zero well we'll try to check it out
we'll try to go zero five ten etc you
better get out of that red circle walk
into the red circle I'm screwed now is
it because you're not in trouble
I hear shooting to somebody
how are you a shrimp or ask a bear
probably till about 12:00 12:30 so we
got another like 45 minutes give or take
are you guys streaming every day I mean
pop G no probably not you two purnima we
stream a variety of different games
usually it's alphas betas previews of
games that we get early or just games
that are like launching on Tuesdays just
for now at least or has been for a while
I've been doing destiny to weekly
updates as they come out and then
Wednesday we normally have Lobby and
then Thursday Friday we'll be filling
with other things there's a couple betas
coming out soon month 100 world I think
we're gonna try to do Dragon Ball
fighters every Friday so stay tuned for
that stuff I don't want this on switch
just people days I don't want this one
switch I'm in trouble I'm pretty far out
I feel like well I don't see the blue
circle closing on you now yeah wisdom
leaf ax I put in the YouTube chat the
patch update notes Oh get in the house
now I gotta go we're going we're going I
think we're gonna die in the red but
alright damn that sucks yeah my right in
the middle T I'm lucky yeah that wasn't
lucky do you have yeah just I'm good I'm
good I'm good
all right here we go I got this let's
put that away
no there's no time to be reloading put
that away
I'm red scant asking what's your most
hype upcoming game at the moment for me
personally it's probably gonna be
fighters Dragonball Fighters that comes
out this month if are looking forward to
some 3v3 action in the inset in the
Dragon Ball universe could be the Marvel
vs. Capcom that we really want and I you
know watch Dragon Ball going up as good
good gotta believe over or under that we
make this I think we're good you're
almost out of the circle like legit so
that's my most upcoming game I mean for
the year there's a lot of solid games so
it's hard to say what happened oh you
to a rock for a second no one ever dies
on the red that's not choose that that's
not room
Sam was telling me on Friday she always
thought it was a myth that you could die
in the red and then she finally died in
the red and realized yeah it could
happen I was in a car and this weekend
it was bang boom we're squads available
in first person you know I didn't even
notice I didn't check I think so I don't
think any of the menus up at the top
changed oh wow
all it says is that first person solo
matchmaking queue will be made available
so I'm not sure about squads oh this is
brutal why you're not even in danger yet
I know but I want to get in some action
I should have went for a car earlier
said it's a road down there right oh
yeah that Avengers game that's true DX
masters I don't know that was a very
quick teaser there was a square-enix
game fpp is only solace as Perry Davis
thank you hello Zanna King whoa
Denice peer I've put in the chat a
couple times what the patch does so just
try to check that out or scroll back to
the beginning of the video why is the
gaming media bias how biased in what
waiver brizl you got a expound upon that
I don't know what we're biased towards
apparently just like PC bitter jo
monster hunter world for sure yeah could
be the first monster hunter you see the
guy can I dive into yeah isn't even a
car though oh no are you gonna live
through this yeah okay could be my first
monster hunter it's just tough because
it's coming out the same day as
Dragonball Fighters which kind of makes
me a little sad but no it is what it is
run faster hide behind the rock yeah
well you only have a medkit so you're
either using the big one or at least
take some painkillers and then someone
else is saying every mode can be played
in first-person
well check when we get out to the all
right let's take a little look look look
see here that's so far you can hit a car
you're gonna have to cross the bridge
too
should I swim try to swim just swim
across here no you told me what's the
best strategy you think uh we're being
told to get in the car I know this is so
boring was even boring for me uh I'm
gonna try to find a car over there but
see that guy know I've been looking at
chat this whole there's a guy right
around the corner that rock yes we're
currently playing on an xbox one X as is
said in the title of the street where do
you go whenever you saw me no definitely
not we're on first person you want to
see me I'm gonna post in chat again
what's new in the update so with he
jumped down and Ville once as a swimming
will take a while I know there is
Burke bristle says not you guys but most
try and badmouth Xbox anyway they can PS
is the golden child that can do no wrong
thanks for streaming you guys I know but
we've been like even GameSpot in general
in terms of like the people always I
wouldn't say always but they they make
that that statement about you know our
favoritism or bias towards PlayStation
the next one I can see why but this is
again personal opinion I just think that
like for me I you're not dropping down
there for me I'm in trouble I've
continued to wait to buy an xbox for
ever now because there hasn't been a
game on xbox I want to play cuphead I
played on PC so for me for the longest
time one of the games I was actually
looking most forward to on an Xbox and
was probably gonna buy an xbox for was
scale about and unfortunately that got
cancelled so now I'm kind of just
sitting here thinking okay like I have
no
oh you got him once someone else is
shooting him see like them let's go
right here you might want to swap the
scopes let's go see me I don't know but
he hid behind the tree dude you're in
the open don't don't fire don't fire
don't fire he doesn't see you and if you
start firing you promise I think we're
gonna get killed by the blue circle all
right well then at least let's follow
that guy him at least get something out
of it so for me personally um there has
just hasn't been anything but we seek me
cz already a or somebody behind me
serpentine oh that guy that guy saw me
finally I shot him oh he's dancing with
you he's dancing oh now it's the Battle
of who can stand straight longer
I think I do right at shootin yeah
they're bullshitting me Oh
find a tree Oh God oh yeah shake and
bake baby we're gonna go that way these
guys are so cool gotta at least kill
that guy oh yeah yeah let him up like a
Christmas tree okay go film it up or
something are you kidding me no you're
good you're good you're good
he's running because he's gonna die to
the blue circle - oh oh he's behind a
car okay okay you got home you have two
met up right cuz you're not gonna live
the blue circle
oh you're you are crate prone Nick is so
cavalier oh my god head up keep it up
you know me - yeah I mean try to live
seven seconds who will live medkit or us
now we're dead if you make it it before
and did you see them oh alright let's go
baby let's go chase that guy he's still
alive there is no aim assist no see so
good hey we're still alive yeah chased
that guy yep there's no thanks Berg I
appreciate it
feel free I mean like we are always open
to constructive criticism all that stuff
where he goes just I don't know he
probably rode the ridge a little bit and
like he went straight down well you
didn't kill him cuz he didn't get
another kill right no how did he live
though I don't have no idea cuz if you
were lighting him up he couldn't have
been
that high up on health I don't know but
you got a book it or find a car
something there's no cars everyone that
was here took cars how do you know that
there's not I mean I all right so we're
dead anyways I mean I can do this if
someone drives by and then I shoot him
out of the car okay but I don't think so
I think we're done all right well what's
up urine and he says set my dudes what
up what up dudes
could he have gotten killed by the other
dude possibly but unlikely right unless
the other guy had a better angle but
that other guy should have been trying
for his life to run too cuz he's just
gonna die to the blue circle like I
always have that in PC 2 if I know that
I'm screwed by the circle am danzo
alright if I know I'm screwed by the
circle then I'll just like try to screw
other people over that are trying to get
into the circle no I don't Sam maybe dad
from the circle Oh was that not give you
a kill
no no oh blues don't kill them is what
you decide yeah probably rain rate drop
there yeah damn all right here we go my
car you probably get one more try unless
you uh go hot and heavy in the beginning
maybe two tries we'll see how we go hot
and heavy there we still 80 no hot and
heavy there was yeah and then you fought
one guy that was like running my fault
nobody on xbox likes to go to the school
how do I get back to regular
is it all be pretty serious right now
no yes it wasn't working I here we go
here we go alright we got it we got to
do better than 10 yeah I saw no boat NC
car let's uh be more methodical here
Matthew Huffman I posted a link in the
YouTube chat showing the article that
has all the patch changes for the
console for Xbox one and One X so check
that out I don't really want to run
through all of them there's some FPS
updates some bug and crash fixes so
alright alright Nick believes he's gonna
go top five top five in the chat in the
chat I want to know if I'm guys believe
him put a one number one if you think
Nick is gonna get top five if you don't
think you can get maybe put it number
two let's go that's gonna put their
number in because I'm game shot right
now
and I'm putting it to goob want to go uh
do one or two goob want to go um I wanna
bet on a bet in twitch tattoo yeah a lot
of two's goob says to easy money
Oh tom hell yes before like one there's
like two ones right now and like a lot
of tubes so yeah - if you don't think
Nick's gonna get in the top five one if
you think that Nick is actually going at
the top five gamespot AKA i have voted
and said that he is not going to get by
all right here all right Nick I will I
will buy us I will buy you lunch another
day if you get top five if you get top
five and do I have to fight you oh no
you don't have to buy you don't have to
buy me lunch if you don't get top five
all right here we're trying to give them
incentive everybody thank you for your
responses I'm seeing a lot of two's
there are some ones in there some threes
which I never played three would be like
I don't know what the option C would be
but uh now there's a lot of ones there
someone's coming through there's some
ones Turkmen Turkmen says definitely one
that's a lot of faith dude there's a lot
of faith here surprisingly I'm shocked
actually you guys got a lot a lot of
faith in our boy here Nick margarita I
don't I don't boot a that's not even a
bet why I can't I feel bad for him well
how do we have done 10 and 18 yeah and
18 we didn't even try really hard for
the 18 could have been better 18
commander do some chick-fil-a some I
don't know chick-fil-a close to the city
though that I know of that's like within
walking distance oh you look I'm dabbing
dabs dab you change your name hon you're
not Daddy no no no this is xbox Oh got
it
I'm uh I'm daddy bye where are you going
where are you going right now go to the
farm okay cuz I don't see anyone around
there we're going to the fob oh no oh
yeah someone's beating you down there
which means you are hoping to beat him
to the punch for the guns okay you're
hoping the Red House has guns how he's
going to the warehouse hopefully he
didn't see you he probably didn't Eric
you should buy all the people who voted
ones lunch
if he gets top five okay you're good you
got it yeah little shoddy got some Oh
dud is that typical shotgun which one is
this oh yes
reload later got a 12-gauge right now
who knows what the other guy has then
you just keep looting yeah there's
nothing in that room okay we are in good
shape we have an assault rifle hopefully
that guy got nothing that's the hope
that's gonna help
she's not gonna reload you're a kay
more ammo not for anything I have though
okay but that the five five six is good
ammo to have I'll bandage probably ting
the other house the other parts of the
farm I could see I had a place Martin
here I'm gonna play very smart because I
want free lunch when did this FDA goal
I've asked Mick Perez I believe today go
through the window I thought you could
jump through windows that one and I
think you just lack the skill us being
quiet sunny oh you wanted to be quiet
you jump through a window turn you up
audio for
okay Gucci we're duty we're getting
first aid is good I don't know the
backpack can you ditch something maybe
something that can you pick it up now
and now they equipped a shotgun choke
probably not I dropped the five five six
Nick really wants this he's gonna die
yeah this guy just breaking through
windows like it's no problem
well just remember that there is a first
aid in that other building later
dude's following him from a distance
maybe you think so no that's what the
chat say oh I hear footsteps
[Music]
he's reloading sakes hey see I told you
put your twos and chance cuz nick is a
hold on alright
biggest buddy a long time hey all my
boys that know Nick margarita hit him up
on his text phone I want him to get
blasted on the text messages do it that
was amazing someone clipped that one
clip Nick margaritas choke Wow me dude
you had him you had a reloading twice
twice Nick I should just walk out of
this stream I'm embarrassed okay
F f to pay respects correct sir chaos
after pay respects goddammit
yeah my friends are [ __ ] all over me
thanks James bro where's his backup
there's no backup he's in so I can't
hear the gameplay all the way off what
do you mean you can't hear he shut the
door for time oh I can't hear right now
oh yeah I turned it down so I could I
could do the choke noisy
you panicked under pressure correct ban
from pop G trash dude that guy mind
after you he like literally was like hey
dude I know you're here I'm gonna shoot
this door down to scare you then I'm
gonna walk in here and kill you god
dammit god dammit
I'm so happy there's so many children
great children that are watching great
cover your ears
oh man I was excellent that is why we
watch streaming everybody know I love it
I hate this I don't know what's worse
that or when you beat me like all tire
altair darius i think you can jump from
a second-story building and not get hurt
that's roughly around when you won't
take fall damage i believe so
alright ones and twos again cuz he wants
double or nothing nothing that he's
gonna get top five put your ones if you
think he's gonna make it into the top
five or as i voted put your twos in
there if you don't think he's gonna make
it
because he died in 68 there double or
nothing this is great this is great tune
in to watch nick choke on some chicken
dinners and now oh my friends are gonna
turn on auto i don't shoot on no I would
have thought you shoot single especially
in close quarters Auto goes I'm with
their friends they're I'm with their
friends are no because it gives you a
higher chance of actually hitting him
instead of whipping over and over oh man
oh alright a lot of two's you you the
faith
I like Felix and twitches a nice dude
thank ya the the face from chat that was
displayed in Game one has now turned it
is now to Katie right saying oh my god I
love you guys thank you so much Katie
yeah i- - that's fair 0yz oh there's
still someone turk Ben who believed in
you Game one it still has faith in you
despite oh thanks homie that
that that choke the choke artists maybe
that'll be here
can we nicknamed you the choke art Nick
the choke artist work yes so no he's not
bad
he's already betting me goop he said
double or nothing but he loses he bought
enough to buy him was you know what I
really just can't want to go get in the
car and just go off the car I see a cars
car over there oh yes Oh get a get a
backpack at some get some meds get some
that's it this is a nice little resource
house here got a first aid already just
yet over to that car energy drinks yes
sick well you can fight people the
sickle no wow
nothing type three to choke alright I'll
type Street that's what's up hey paid
there was a pay pay the horse of by a or
valet
all right he's got a gun m16 solid gun
we're leaving this area no car hey my
tummy yeah so what are you getting for
lunch date don't know yet that's a good
question
there's a lotta there's a lot of good
spots around our office pretty good
pretty good
I believe in you kill him all says
heartless okay he's gonna get top fifty
maybe lower man that's not saying much
Calvin Collins wants you to try to play
a little bit more stealthy he was trying
to play stealthy there that I just went
on a manhunt like I decided to follow
Nick and beast was right he was
following in a distance like the guy
knew where he was because even though
Nick closed all the doors he he
creeper he pre fired his shotgun as he
came up the stairs and then he also knew
Nick was in that room because he shot
the door
let's way off the flight path go up to
like how about checking out the new
account settings we kind of did that a
little bit earlier Jesse Oscarsson main
main thing is the is that the aim the
the aim acceleration was one of the
bigger options yeah the door closing did
alert him like oh by the way I'm over
here thanks to our brothers appreciate
the kind words loving the channel thank
you maybe the guy was watching you're
twitching highly doubt it no how would
they know that pancake face Wow
how would they know pancake face is a
nick margarita oh he's just going to
hide amen
you can you can survive a long game of
pub G just kind of chillin
yeah I agree autofocus he wasn't playing
stealthy he was smashing windows that's
true I did say that I did say that
jumping through the windows was gonna
alert people he was he was going to Shh
but he was making all the noise in the
world
ah where you going I'm going to rock
because I know no one's up there and
look how you know no one's up there if
no because of the flight path my path
was like down by the island so Oh as
somebody is doing what I'm doing he was
definitely not killed because of lag or
frame jobs that was due to poor aim Oh
terribly anyone I know I have absolutely
like a lot of the freezing has been
fixed Sam wrote like Andy Reid in the
Kansas City Chiefs we have no excuse we
didn't finish the game Harrison but Kurt
missed the 42-yard field goal that's
where they lost the game he wasn't cause
of Alex Smith granted their offense it
stalled and they didn't have Travis
Kelce he's like go to saying
please test aims acceleration will test
it as the last thing I got to give Nick
his juice
double or nothing here as in the last
game will we will literally just test
aim acceleration I will will go past all
30s - hello really help someone - by the
way the red stones in the air kissing we
haven't crashed at all um level 3
backpack stay well the house of
backpacks right here in Rock ooh a
little level 2 level 1 fest and a pan
I don't like the sks 2x scope too by the
way
why don't you just take that for now
right what is the new update based on
AIM acceleration bug fixing and also FPS
client-side and server-side slight
increases or like slightly better oh
great
alright so far so good
nick has not encountered anyone
therefore giving him a greater chance of
survival sorry
accommodate the the comity commentary
here is riveting oh you didn't see that
other assault rifle that was there I
don't know I definitely saw another
rifle there was yeah why don't just be
am 16 they fixed most of the crashes but
they didn't say exactly which crash is
in particular it just says fixed a lot
of bugs and whatnot
up the I think they up the damage on
fallen recently because I usually make
that jump and not have any problems and
I just didn't hurt man Nick hates
Windows spite you oh that helmet you
need a helmet good here this is not a
wee thing okay this is this is uh it was
a mini 14 years when I have a long
gaming said that's what it was it's fine
dude I kind of want it though Wow who
was it on top of that one that says I
think it's on top of this building I
know Jerry says Andy with the well I
love the mini 14 okay did he put a site
on the sks no it's you're right I don't
know it's no no behind you behind you
behind you know whatever that is that's
the shotgun goes s12 you fools
yeah well my bed is not a cheek oh it's
a cheek was my bed he put the scope on
his m14 a thing yeah there's two times
that's in time two times yeah I know
normally on PC that would be blasphemy
and I would put it on this what is it
that's KS but he's not using
earlier the aiming is as you can don't
trade mini for SKS yeah I think that's
probably the right move DX masters is
just like everyone has their different
play styles and and also it's probably
harder to snipe you know so hard to
sleep on console it's hard to shoot
someone when they're in the same room as
you
only for you Nick ah thanks to whoever
twitch clip that that's gonna be a good
one well share it around
Monday mornings am i right guys are so
nice to me
dan lets us cast is gonna be lip though
I don't know if there's an actual Sasuke
but he says shut it Sasuke you goddamn
weave if I'm Sasuke that's pretty cool
I'll be I'll be a weeb and I'll be
Sasuke because that's Ches a badass
I don't know what you guys are talking
about anime naruto sasuke
is like the not the main protagonist he
would probably like a close second
behind it Naruto it's like his bitter
rival who's more talented than him and
has the shutting in specialized so are
you guys saying that hey is my rival
oh no there is a Sasuke in chat and he's
more skilled now yeah I am more skill
didn't you know that your Naruto you got
a you got a hope that hard work pays off
for you whereas for me I was already
gifted you look take a holo watching for
the hollow on the m16 and then put the
scope 1 to 2 times on the SKS and then
not pick up that first day somebody's
here I hear that yeah I turned it up for
you
Oh
is he gone no that's a bio indeed it's
very much here it is my ninja way you
take your car
not sure I think he took your us
this is waiting Arab
hold on let me use my Shetty get to find
out where this oh you're in the red zone
well maybe that truck will get red so
that'd be hilarious yes you are safe in
the red zone as long as you hide in the
houses Stream sniper and envy ask me
favorite anime ooh that's tough that's
real tough man is it possible the stream
snipe yeah but would there be delayed
they'd only know where you're at
there's no year in Roz Hawk that's about
it but is it possible to join like a
specific oh that's true I don't know
like with pub gee I don't know if you
can't uh top anime is envy that's tough
get some good ones Gurren Lagann code
Gaius what's my favorite Gundam he's
gonna wing Naruto had its ups and downs
oh holy snap which was good to start and
then it kind of got not so great what
else did i watch one punch definitely
watch one punch watch I might hear
academia
I like Hajime no Ippo GTOs a teacher
onizuka okay any anime gonna watch this
season yes definitely gonna watch the
seven sins not Natsu note I say ties
it's been a long time since I come out
so definitely gonna watch that forget
what else is out this in the winter
commander man there's more stuff coming
out later people steam shower out every
day and man yeah that is true autofocus
but he also has like 40,000 people
watching him
Kevin Jacques Jacques says Sasuke is not
more talented they're even really do you
really feel that Sasuke and Naruto are
even from like a young age look at how
much harder Naruto has to work to get
anywhere power level wise compared to
Sasuke so 210 get rid of the do you want
to say he's more gifted to start do I
know why isn't he taking em for what
someone who's asking well do I get her
you're not gonna snipe then get rid of
the SKS and take that point I think I am
first we're gonna do that I take that
416 is what Ryan would do looking
forward to the new for recurring yeah
mmm
sequel to wait wait there's a sequel to
basilisk the adult Naruto huh maybe I'll
check that out fix blue exorcist is good
too it's just so the anime is so far
behind though I'm getting gaming with
hallisay sasuke better and before is
god-tier wait we're talking about anime
now I just got sidetracked I talk about
anime sorry if you don't want to we
could stop well there's not much going
on either in this game as NYX looting
and playing real safe because he wants
to get that top 5
[Music]
also you could argue uh well depends on
how you look at it you could argue that
Naruto has a jinchuriki like the
strongest one and Sasuke doesn't well it
Sasuke is born with shine again yeah
whatever
ah I'll talk more about anime when we do
the Dragonball Fighters stream how about
that back to Nick who's still looting
and has not killed anyone right oh the
bike
you're in the circle right yep who share
my shampoo good one cowboy bebop as well
these houses are filled though I know
who Tokyo ghoul also good empty kind of
like sequel but the sequel the guy kind
of took liberties and did his own thing
hole okay you changed the narrative the
logo which is fine I guess
I haven't watched enough little witch
academia yellow Sanchez I think Kelly
likes well which I could date me a bit
kind of you here what about the new plow
Linton's battle guys haven't tried it
toxic striker I don't know I look I look
good right is it is a Dragonball
Fighters stream already scheduled hoping
for Friday supinator if not Oh probably
Monday okay now camping this building
for the rest of the match this mo one
gaming did you take that for you did
right God do not learn I don't want it
to be boring for you guys so I want it
to be like exciting well what do you
want do you want it to be exciting or do
you want to actually do what you said
you're gonna do but I don't want it to
be boring for you alright so you know
what I mean you're at your your lunch -
oh not them
Turkmen Turkmen says Nick is like John
Cena you can't see him
go kill some people and stop hiding says
Kim kilee yeah see like I I agree with
you like if I was watching stream I
would want to watch someone get after it
go kill a bunch of people I don't think
you have enough five five six ammo just
saying that no mo carcasses don't worry
so much about being boring yeah we're
we're here to win it I mean if you see
someone then you know I don't care why
am i why am I telling you how to play
whatever you want you know it's to get
top five where is this guy keep hearing
them sounds like Texas Chainsaw Massacre
[Music]
nice and money you guys take a lot of
items to die 1v1
whoever loose us is gonna get a booty a
bounty nice little our backpack is so
filled
you guys wear shoes in your mom's
basement sometimes just depends that's
how I'm feeling
Nick calls this strategy window open
right cuz I didn't go out that door
right don't remember I haven't been
keeping track of your what's the verdict
better the same I think slightly
slightly better it can do a 1 in terms
of having the update d even pub G says
Polly Adams only sometimes him camping
isn't making his viewers happy campers
Dan the tarantula man Sasuke was born in
a wealthy family aka the Uchiha Naruto
was kind of born into a poor situation
but his dad was a Hokage literally the
president of the hidden leaf no family
and Sasuke had advantage from an early
age just depends on how you look at it
but yes I I don't disagree necessarily
with that also the Uchiha has got
eradicated spoilers
so one saying get a weapon with a new
ammo type yeah but I have so much I'm
not gonna tell him what fire rate to put
it on because apparently he loves
singing oh look look look we got this on
auto ok dad on single ok thank you
everybody happy the funny thing is
everyone else is probably doing the same
thing right now which is hiding in the
house
hit me 1990 what's your opinion of the
game right now I don't play enough so
it's hard for me to say hello enjoy I
enjoy watching it I enjoy kind of like
watching Jake and Nick play at the end
of the day when they're doing their like
few matches before they go home I love
this game mainly because I got the troll
Nick you know it is funny like a couple
weeks ago we were playing and we choked
we choked and we're in the final two
team actually it was like right around
here remember mmm
Jake went out and got killed around the
corner and I tried to avenge him and I
got smoked and we what we should have
done is we both should is weighted and
so Tay walked out
you know just porn pouring on us just
absolutely pouring on us in the very
next game we went in one but he'd
already gone home a bit epic milk LV
brings up a good point he says I will
never be good with controller but I'm
stuck playing this version with my our
IRL friends that don't use PC yeah I
think that's a lot that's a fair amount
of people because like even for Nick
it's like playing with for him to play
with his buddies he also has sorry I
thought I heard footsteps for him to
play with his buddies he's got a play on
console whereas like you know in the
office he plays PC with Jake I think the
same for Jake Jake probably plays
console with you yeah yeah Jake and I
play with his buddies from back home on
a console sometimes taking naps and pub
do you heck yeah I take take those naps
whatever it takes to get a chicky dinner
what do you guys want me to do I move
this planet ass and play with you guys
in the office - oh she hasn't but that
could change at any time I don't think
Sam has any cat Mac I see you oh he's a
guy guy I just walked right up by that
wall
all right we got some peeps
I got some homies in the area you sound
like Joe Rogan I'll go get him
we got I got you Alex what is the most
amount of people you've killed in the
game asking patriotic castle 9 on pc 3
on xbox go away - for me i've only
played like less than five matches and
they were on console I don't know why I
did that to myself and ville one gaming
akr Ryan Schubert outside says I
wouldn't move I know he's a guy see the
guy
see ya he's looting houses man he really
doesn't want to take you to lunch no he
does it Jay Baer no I don't are you
kidding me tag of a bag of us says kulli
Adams Oh hopefully we tag somebody I
don't think either of us are gonna go
into our thoughts about our Logan Paul
incidents that's just opening a huge can
of worms I'm good off that there's
enough people talking about that that we
don't need to I don't know too much
about him you know then then like that
cut like that gave him more attention if
anything yeah he just drove off
think so he was done with this area and
said f it all those doors are open let's
see where it's going are you okay no
that's your location your yellow circles
where you're at is it going Oh time to
go to school baby
time to go to school oh no I thought you
were too cool for school there he is
he's up there but you're not you better
not have a long scope on your ass dude
there's no way you know that guys snipe
somebody when are you gonna make the
move Dan the transfer oh man make a good
point sometimes you gotta pick your
fights the key to survival that is
correct
Turk Ben is still firmly in the belief
camp
we can't wait for everyone to die
watchman he's got to kill at least one
person to get first although to get top
five I guess technically doesn't have to
kill anyone that guy's definitely gonna
go into those houses right I know he's
going up the hill uh do you know if
running without a weapon is faster than
running with a wife yeah Jake and I
tested that it's faster go what's the
best loadout you ever has ask me Clark's
are you ready ready yeah go for it we're
going and then you can answer that
question later
hi we'd like goals we'd like to vault
game what's the best loadout you've ever
had game pop G me yeah I've had I really
like the mini 14 m16a4 combo okay Nick
per the same AM okay make Perez brings
up a good point you can't stream tonight
all you have to do is look for the
server name at the bottom of the screen
which does show and then kind of keep
joining games or leaving games until
they get that server it is random but
yeah you have the chance so did this
update actually fix the game at all or
there's still three crashes dad you're
I'm it should be better that they made a
blanket statement saying that one of the
fixes was for the bugs and crashes so we
haven't gotten a crash but we're on an
Xbox 1x right now yeah I'm gonna be
honest I don't think I've had my game
crash on my ex yet now might might we
were playing over break on my buddy's
original Xbox and it crashed so I
crashed a ton
all right you got to think that's some
no distracting with question no that's
the whole point I'm trying to get a
lunch here Ryan
geez you gotta answer is Ryan there's no
need to be nervous yet just still 25
people I am panicking
really you're that I wouldn't be nervous
you got another like well it depends on
how bad this next circle is for you
distract what he's the best camper
that's true Misa Amane jam 481 I'll try
to check out erased thank you for a guy
there's guy we already played in big
first person Big Bang are you gonna
you're not there's no reason to yeah
that's why I thought chicken why are you
so chicken oh yeah that circle that
circle you got to make it dude you don't
have time to facepalm right now the
apartments you don't have time to
facepalm right now okay make it happen
make it happening there's no way dude
you only have to survive 14 more people
and you're gonna get that top five just
by camping he's pitching a tent
don't panic at the disco you still like
Pontiac you guys go quite a bit they
went folky for a bit and I didn't like
that too much I mean a turkey dinner I
think I gotta go right yeah you got you
got to do something you can't sit in
this this there's so many people that
are gonna be running up this hill though
right I don't know you tell me
sorry about that that's right
hopefully that guy's out to your right
the guy that was climbing the hill that
your fake shooting with your OS I think
is that guy is that backpack I called it
I told you he was up there bro I am 100%
told you and you looked hella late you
looked at the tree were you looking at
the tree or him I look like a tree but
as I was looking at the tree I saw him
and I was like dude why did you not look
there when you saw that guy crawl up the
hill that's the first place you should
have checked
I get lunch that's hot awesome all right
and on oh you know what go into a game
real quick so we can test out the game
acceleration or every person turn on it
doesn't have to be first person cuz you
can toggle the first person in nan first
person right do you want me to just do
first person no just do it in TPP third
person and then we'll just change will
check zero versus ten oh man yeah I shot
like twice I didn't shoot I was leaving
the tree oh man you're killing me just
literally killing me man Wow
I owe teh lunch you know what I should
have played this match and see if I can
do better than you just kidding I don't
want to know it's gonna take too long I
don't want to camp it out 35 come on
just so you can say that you did better
than all right 60 I don't know buns I
don't know the buttons shoot I know
shoot but like all the pickup stuff oh
yeah so hold down start alright so I had
to 16 so all he's got to do is get above
60 I actually think you let me let me
see if we can mess with this right now
thanks for all that believed in me I
don't notice the difference here in
punching at zero aim acceleration versus
like oh alright
so no hands oh so X is your action is F
those like you're it's like you're
paying around I interact okay hold down
X to reload
yeah yeah to toggle between Ames Fire
Eagle upad toggle to the to the left is
gonna be burst J eject we're try to each
act that eject this B I know but we're
Shia check your map check your mouth
select save on doc Wow it's right along
the flight path so you're gonna have a
ton of people
so we're shy draw pocket uh if you want
to play it safe that's cool I would try
to go you crazy try to go up to like
stubbornly try to go to several you're
gonna get it's cool I'm feeling you're
dying really quick but okay yeah guys
driving away faster than me I don't even
know if I'm dropping towards the school
oh that's a school what's uh what's that
thing to the right of the school what's
that the apartment yeah that's the left
over here um Felix says you two should
stream the game again that's fun
thanks dude I felt like I did really
lousy but I'm gonna die real fast I'm
gonna make it smell your good be know
I'm gonna make it spicy dude I'm gonna
go look for action nah but I want to get
some weapons first I don't want to have
that weird awkward duel where it's like
okay so I tried to aim okay right now I
have a mcc's el eration at zero or
whatever that means
hello oh there you go okay
Bulmer says hey GameSpot please give my
brother a shout-out he's involved in it
what what are you doing oh he's in an
accident oh yeah shout it to your
brother man hope he feels better cuz
things are rough for us I hope you feel
better man yeah man much loved alright
this is apparently like one of Sam's
favorite guns which apparently nobody
likes I hate this gun so confirmed
nobody likes it yeah but I I mean 762 so
I think it's I think it's one of the
more deadly damage yeah yeah she got
headshot it like randomly it looked like
or about one of these yeah yeah yeah I I
believe I'll leave the door open meta
well this early and like where you are
oh you're in a good spot for the circle
though just a start
all right so once ones or twos Forte
here for what though I'm not gonna get
top five well no to beat to beat me so
Tata so some 16 of 16 I'm not I'm not
gonna be too considering I'm gonna go no
place magan's baby yolo swaggins we go
this a little like fake lighthouse it's
the wizard tower I'm off to see the
woods well Molly Molly Molly Molly
alright people are done already
I use the vault yep oh it feels kind of
slow I wonder if that's because of the
what's that I'll tell ya Tommy I thought
that things trashed though so you kinda
you kinda have to like go slowly when I
like picking things up you need to need
to find a backpack do I park maybe
upstairs I'll take that vest though
hey what's up chat I haven't been
looking at you guys the entire time so
hi I give myself a little bit more audio
here umm so real sergeant Tomlinson off
you PC guys are so better why aren't you
playing that right now because there's
an update today there was an update for
the Xbox version when you wanted to
check it out should probably pick up a
shotgun and say my nice well to my a
handgun or wait that doesn't matter
because I am yeah I mean I'm not an Xbox
but I just pcs much more refined and
that's obviously gonna be much more fun
because it's been around longer you know
all right so what I mean now helmets low
is ebert keep the shotgun tommy gun
combo I guess so you're at zero right
now right you're at zero for the
accelerate know the acceleration at zero
aim acceleration
[Music]
you want more shells are there give a
little to you quite fit it so we are
kind of testing it I not personally sure
the difference though because I haven't
tried it at a higher there's yeah hey I
know it's now the shells
um what's spec oh that's an 8k that's an
EI k and you already have some 760 from
the pistol so going to go into like your
your menu and then just pick it up there
yeah so yeah X to pick up those items
and then like a - like equip them and we
have no sights or anything no I like and
anyone I think it's like fanboy hate or
whatever nice level to holo sight I just
said Auto equip the holo cider now now
you'll have to do it you can a PC really
quickly like so use the bumper scroll to
the side yeah yeah
alright so okay I will say complaint you
might want to put that jack on I'll make
you it'll cover your body with look at
dark color yeah the inventory management
needs to be adjusted
it's it's a nightmare no it's a it's
kind of a nightmare
I have you worried about the circle or
not yet now you're in you're in ok but I
mean just in terms of it moving I find
that like when I'm in the final circle
like when I try to like quickly pop like
some meds or like get some painkillers
and like make some moves it's so
painfully difficult to do it with a
controller versus like the easiness that
you have with a keyboard
that I just if you want to drop stuff
hit Y so what do you think do you think
it's gonna go towards Gatka no idea
those bushes are tight means you can
just stand them and now I can see it's a
car isn't it somewhere
I li did that Alex right yeah sometimes
there's a motorcycle in that sometimes
there's a motorcycle
I see the streamers do a lot of running
yeah I also agree with plums II
chameleon the game doesn't run that bad
that's a bike there's a bike Oh with a
guy laying right next to it you see him
how do i 80s uh so select select one in
go to shoot shot nice new tactics here I
didn't even know how to 80s you want the
you don't know now it's x4 items a to
equip certain things well I want is m16
right so yeah put it down on the shotgun
yep take his other 5 sects yeah hit a
again hit a again there you go
now go ahead take us five five six with
X and that's it you're gonna get enough
I can get going cool
do you want to be in first person
anymore no how do I get our first person
oh [ __ ] you're in the backseat
get out I don't know what you did they
go that's a right bumper okay there you
go how do i 80s though just tap into the
left left trigger one app once instead
of holding tap no to tap in hold is like
yeah
all right already doing better than Nick
guys kill wise talk about the other
games we're coding the other get one
kill there we're looking for Oh Oh what
are you doing I have no idea how to ride
a motorcycle apparently I didn't get
home it's gonna be fine what was that I
don't know this guy's trying to BMX
tricks we're going to do some Shaun
White moto moto wins all the big stuff
here all right took some big damage Raja
rocks rocks should be fine right now
right the hot hot area no I know but
like in terms of like in the circle oh
this door is open okay somebody was here
that doors are open there hi did you
leave any bandages be honest it's six
individual there are a lot of games that
come out and they're not a lot of people
and so hey you know obviously hasn't
played this game as much as like maybe
me or tiny needs one more kill to pass
the next record what are you talking
about such a bully goob you're such a
bully good job keep it up ight it you
want to put your holo sight in the room
416 ma I'm 64 so just hit a and hit a
again yep someone's here someone's here
all day baby that's what we do here we
just we just spam button how do you not
see ballistic mask
yeah energy drink for Sayed that's seven
six to you I take that level three no
take the seven six to the level three is
pretty messed up and you have a well um
that's up to you Oh red dot
what you need that for to excope oh yeah
it's good or should I have a 2x on your
m16 or your a K and you have a hollow on
your penny a flash hider if you want I
need to go MIT up gonna hide in the
bathroom do you not have a helmet no I
don't take his but you have a helmet
yeah I think you feeling good right now
Keith Richards I love you who do I got
in the game tonight
go dogs how do i how do i I think I'll
go there guys hold down hold down on the
c fashion that why is his loot thing not
working oh there you go
where's his helmet he wasn't wearing one
no oh yeah it was the mask then he
wasn't
yeah love it national championship
tonight ESPN for ABC I guess I'm pretty
excited Alabama Georgia go Dawgs even
though I think Alabama's getting the dog
well I just talk girlies former team I'm
tired I'm really tired
I'm not gonna lie I was s car now it's
what you have but take that the five
five six yeah so we haven't found any
boosts and I don't have a helmet yet
you're gonna get bombed 200s stay in
here then right ask and you shall
receive
I just gotta stay in here right for the
bombs
oh yeah yeah I mean rats other ones you
should be okay but I'm gonna chill yeah
I'm with you Keith I just
I'm sick of Bama being in the national
championship oh we gotta go how do I
mark this I press in on ya reload your a
case somebody said I did reload my
account okay that's why I just did yeah
yeah you wanna drop that pistol because
it just becomes another thing useful so
you would go into your inventory
don't forget hide go into your inventory
these the bumper all the way to the
right and
yep and then hit why not the red zone
yeah the bombing they've updated it so
it's really really loud thank you no
bandwagon jumper hey what's up steel
forged how are you where we gone where's
my map
that a car in the distance mm I don't
think so I am going the right way though
yeah you are
gunfire would be nice to get some boosts
you have no painkillers or energy
transit oh my god I picked up the one
guy's energy drink yeah one do you feel
like is best to use the energy Thanks uh
I saved for the end and I popped two at
a time
hey what's up I'm watching from England
says Matt Vernon oh four thanks dude we
appreciate the college two of them
uno dos are they playing cat and mouse
here yeah for sure the other dudes chase
them so don't let them know where you
are also I don't think you can reach
Italy you gotta go though I do yeah I
feel like you you're gonna want to like
run into that guy just went prone pop
him well actually no the oh yeah cuz the
other guys shooting at him and so he's
trying to hide I don't know if you have
the distance here for it though oh you
hit him maybe he's hitting him oh yeah
getting him from downtown but uh [ __ ]
from way downtown
we just got booked it can you run while
the maps out and motorcycle up there can
you what can I like hold the mat oh oh
oh that guy just teleported me glitching
a little bit oh I'm almost to the circle
then if I if I put in where I my
location but it could get frisky here
all right she's got a tap tap what's up
Ellie its high from Spain
it's got taps glad to have our
international audience in here we love
all of you like
yeah I'm not good with the angling of
the of the scope - because you can do
that - right the wing aha I love I love
this comp I'm real sergeant Tom I like
watching guys that aren't expert players
beats it like I do great it's like it's
more fun because we do dumb things you
know even though I do you you were big
you watch a lot of red zone I mean just
because you watch doesn't it just love
the old habits okay you guys we know
that's exploded okay mmm here I keep
going
really yeah the blue circles catching up
to you I mean though no you're not
you're not you're not yeah you're not in
okay don't run through the water either
it slows you down but then the red zones
right there that's a risk it
Wow that's up to you well I didn't know
I was gonna go slower in the waters oh
yeah you can hold Y and like put away
your guns it makes you run faster if you
want
oh man love for India oh god I'm running
to the road I'm running through the red
now I don't feel good about this if I
died over there that's the Blues right
behind me
throw loud that was really close and the
blue this is everybody loves an
undergrad underdog story I love it
it's why go dogs tonight underdogs I
thought you meant me the underdog
well yeah you are an underdog I mean how
many times you play this on console you
played it once online by like less than
five doing medkit here um I wouldn't
worry about that I like to keep my
health topped off though you're very far
though again from the next circle and
you only have was that little three
helmet right there oh it's a little
three backpack
I'll take you help me whoa big pickups
no one came to the room dang dude steel
forge from India bricks from Sweden hi
from Washington says Jay Baer what's up
everyone love from California hey Ally
what up Cali
level two we got to book it right yeah
oh there's gotten Hill yeah yeah yeah we
stock them roll tide boom here's where
we'll put vaulting to the test man I
can't believe how much I take vaulting
for granted yeah
mantle that wrong when you couldn't do
that in the past Oh brutal hello from
Belgium says the mighty lobster
if you have some bandages you might heal
but don't forget 45 seconds the blue
circle is gonna come and now that it's
the second time it's gonna be stronger
than the first time I have two med kits
and a bunch of bandages what is that car
right in front of you yeah he's right uh
he's like driving really slowly see him
yeah that person
oh yeah he's driving oh that one I'm
buggy so I know what happened so this
happens sometimes your game a hard crash
you'll be in a vehicle when you go back
into the game and you go back into the
vehicle the vehicle will only go like
really slowly
it's brutal three two one booster going
come in
I don't know where I need to get to who
Nick you gotta go through this field
which socks do I yeah we're gonna go
somebody says heal up use the med kit
there's a dune buggy right there
hopefully doesn't look back whoo
what think we're a lot I was talking
about football Kerby smarts defense got
to give Nick Saban's off in some trouble
the chubs and the Mike hell dude Mike
Hill and chub
I can't wait those two deadly a rushing
combo I'm actually pretty excited oh
you're good you're good you're almost in
circle but watch it still legs chill
like once I get there should I go to
that building chillin like scoped out
the building maybe no but the building
is a building in yeah boost up I don't
have any boosts I might have one boost I
hear a car though oh he's gotta be right
behind you watch out also watch if
someone's inside this house because
there's no items on the ground right
there which is weird
Oh somebody's in there that was scary I
tried I literally tried to 80s and I
ended up getting that shitty 80s yeah
it's tough to like remember versus other
ways the blue the blue is closing in
though huh I'm not actually in the
circle no no no
if you push to the other house you will
be him oh go quick cuz the circles right
there seven six two five five six see if
he's got any healing items you're good
on scopes did you have any brutes I
didn't see any no he hasn't
military best three yeah I take that
because it's not as damage yeah alright
go go go oh wait you have time actually
do I oh yeah sorry that's the next
circle well you can think it's truck if
you want
760 on the ground there so we are
playing on the Xbox 1x you know goob
this wasn't a family channel I have some
choice words for you you said you have
more kills than I do I do have more
kills than you though that is a fact
that is an actual fact though we just
lucked out though real talk he's trashed
called trash she's killed three dudes
hey I'm sorry the aiming is not good
this is like probably a my like my less
than I probably only played about do I
have a higher than two best there's a
two vests give a three okay but it's oh
yeah I dropped it
this is probably my less than tenth game
on console here so there's no peopie's
they can all be peeps in here a little
bit of a break here okay that's a broken
car they gonna be peeps here nope but
there's a boost I got a bunch so I
should chill at this house right till
the next circle yeah watch those doors
shut no movies there well unless that's
bait wait that's an SKS careful cuz
somebody's popping smoke near you like a
lot of smoke yeah somebody's down there
well that's weird this is 80s well yeah
so when you're close to the window you
would have to stand up for it to look
down your sights you have to kind of be
back so like go into it now yeah when
you're like to close oh I don't want to
80s though like you know how I was like
really close to that other guy did
you're sniping now I like to shoot from
like third person from the hitting it's
smaller than this no you're good yeah
yeah but oh yeah it'll get to the size
of the building you're in if it gets
there alright four more four more and
we're tied man mo you launched
three more three more whoo let's go guys
let's go there are mods Asian persuasion
I am bill one is a mod I'll take you a
nice lunch why oh nice guy
yeah time no yeah time two minutes till
it goes oh I should boost up frame rates
locked at thirty we're playing on the
Xbox 1x people are saying use energy
drink sir he's gone he used it
you can't hit people in the head with a
frying pan 17 live come on like I was
afk or something where he died to the
play zone well no he's probably wait he
was probably out there with no car how
far did it was pretty far right or where
we had to go uh relatively it's gone oh
we're here yeah we got a lot of people
got faith in you a lot of people faith a
lot of cars she's getting a car just
drive around circle Heidi
that's your [ __ ] I'm here to do that now
I'm saying that's a strat that you would
employ I don't know I did not employ I I
said that you would want to I would she
I would want to but I wouldn't for the
fidelity of the stream well there's a
guy right there
oh my god there's another guy right
there yeah it's gonna be a hot bed it's
just awkward no yeah are you gonna go in
well we're not in the circle right now
though Oh God dang lit it's okay you
tell art we're tied we're tied
oh I'm winning if you're winning he's
won he's won he won lunch damn it
nice nice if somebody damaged him cuz he
went down quick there's gotta be someone
up here well don't go up them coop
here
there is do you tell you should've been
playing this whole time why was I
playing
don't look don't lose you have plenty of
stuff just take the 761 get out of there
take this 7-6 to and take the boost
because people don't even come upstairs
oh no we gotta go somewhere else but you
a minute just chill just chill how do
you yeah you a minute 12 so you have to
move and it's not gonna take you that
long to get there
you could probably run with the circle
at this point I boost now check to see
if there's anyone in this room Shay
boost now let's go chai boost come on
Tay so you don't think I should go yet
ah because you're gonna go out in the
open do you think that guy has
painkillers careful Oh nobody had boost
that's up to you you wanna move alright
doing it okay
Oh Sam Sam Sam he sees you ah
reload reload reload
I failed you all you still do better
than me one lunch God that was good dude
I choked so hard there oh yeah my aim
was so awful no salvo who choked harder
me in the room with the other guy that
shot me dude
that guy killed near the micro uzi it
feels bad I was trying to 80s the whole
time like please 80s he shouldn't feel
bad that was awesome alright just want
to say thank you guys all for tuning in
to the Xbox one update to pub G it's out
today Xbox one and Xbox one X helps with
the frame rate both client side and
server side also there's optimization
physics performance enhancements server
oh I just said server VFX receive slight
optimizations you can now have the
option of turning music on and off fix a
bunch of crashes and bugs and then also
aim acceleration is now in the game you
can adjust it zero to ten I had it at
zero can I have no gauge of how to tell
the difference sorry sign I think it's
like sign nine earlier those are tested
weapon damage has been increased against
vehicles which is also cool they'll be
monitoring that to see how it goes first
person a in solo matchmaking queue is
also available now so you guys can do
that and some other stuff but anyways
thanks Nick for plane Chetan hanging out
yeah and thanks everyone for hanging out
and chatting with us we are alive every
day at 11 a.m.
except this Wednesday and maybe next
Wednesday lobbies on a little bit of a
break as we kind of clean up the studio
and the control room a bit
so thank you guys all for tuning in and
hit that subscribe follow and until next
time when we do some pub G maybe y'all
maybe I'll get a chicken dinner one day
one day one day one day we'll get a
chickadee alright roll tide alright yeah
alright see you guys bye